[Music]
my next guest is a writer on Saturday
Night Live whose new stand-up special
John Mulaney new in town airs on Comedy
Central this Saturday at 10:00 p.m.
please welcome the very funny
John Mulaney hi how are you my name's
John Mulaney I hope you're doing well
I'm doing very well myself I am about to
be 30 years old which is very exciting
but I was hoping that by now thank you
I was hoping that by now I would look
older and I don't I don't look older at
all I just look worse that's what's
happened like when I'm on the street now
nobody's ever like Hey look at that man
they're just like whoa that tall child
looks terrible get some rest tall child
you can't keep burning the candle at
both ends I have a girlfriend now and
she's a woman and she's great I love her
very much and our relationship is going
well so a few months ago she said that
it was time for her to meet my parents
because that is what people do when a
relationship is going well they meet
each other's parents and I have never
understood that I've never been with my
girlfriend and thought oh babe tonight
is going great
but do you know what would make it
perfect Charles and Ellen Mulaney yeah
let's get them in the mix we've been
going pretty hot and heavy lately I
think it's time we bring in two older
Catholic people I live in New York City
it's a great place and I was coming home
the other night I won't tell you about
this I was coming home and in front of
my building on the street I saw a
wheelchair knocked over on its side with
no one in it that is such a bad thing to
see something happened there you hope it
was a miracle
but probably not probably something
worse than a miracle New York is very
safe though it's a very safe city
because on most streets they're filming
Law & Order Special Victims Unit they're
always doing that that's my favorite
show on television I love Law & Order
SVU because on SVU you can say the
grossest sickest things you've ever
heard in your life you can say anything
on us for you no you can't say the F
word but people walk around on that show
going like looks like the victim has
anal contusions looks like we found
semen and fecal matter in the victims
ear canal those are two real things that
I heard on Law & Order Special Victims
Unit at 3 o'clock in the afternoon both
spoken by ice-t I see is a detective
with the Special Victims Unit he handles
New York's most sensitive cases I love
ice tea on SVU he's awesome and what I
especially love about him is that he's
been with the SVU Oh about 11 years now
but he still treats every case like it's
his first in terms of total confusion
like they will be in the middle of an
investigation and ice-t will just be
like yo you telling me this dude gets
off on little girls with pigtails
like yeah ice he's a pedophile you work
in the sex crimes today you're gonna
have to get used to that
oh there was this one episode recently
with the episode was about sex addiction
so they were talking about sex addicts
and there was a scene where the other
detectives are trying to teach ice-t
what sex addiction is and it takes a
couple of minutes and finally ice-t gets
it and they cut to him in this close-up
and he goes oh I get it you mean like
when someone drinks too much snorts
cocaine or bets the house on the ponies
and I was psyched that ice-t understood
and then they could move on with the
investigation but I could have watched
another four hours of him just naming
examples just that shot of iced tea and
him like or like when someone smokes too
many cigarettes or like when someone
shops too much for credit cards
or like when someone plays too many
Scratchy lotteries or like when someone
eats too much chocolate cake or like
when someone eats too much chocolate
cake and then barks it up and he would
just keep talking and it would slowly
fade out and say executive producer Dick
Wolf
that'd be my idea so thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]